bonjour à toutes et à tous alors
aujourd'hui je vais vous inviter à vous
ramener à votre condition d'être vivant
en fait et dans toute sa simplicité qui
absorbe des éléments qui les digère pour
grandir ou simplement pour sa survie et
qu'il est prête
pour parler plus trivialement on va
parler pipi caca
en fait je vais essayer de vous
convaincre sur le fait que si la gestion
actuel du pipi caca et un peu la cause
de notre part et ben ça peut être l'arme
pour notre salut. Alors va démarrer par
l'alimentation en fait depuis notre
depuis la révolution verte en fait et
ben on importe des engrais parce que les
sols ont perdu énormément en fertilité
en France et on importe principalement
trois éléments qui sont l'azote le
phosphore et le potassium alors on va
démarrer par le cycle de l'azote qui lui
depuis la Seconde Guerre mondiale en a
trouvé un processus qui permet de
transformer l'azote de l'air en azote
solide qu'on appelle les ammonitrate
seulement il y a besoin d' énormément
d'énergie pour faire ça particulièrement
du gaz et donc c'est plutôt dans les
pays extracteur de gaz qu'on fait ça
notamment dans le Golfe donc on va
produire tout ça pour produire une tonne
d'ammonitrate et ben on a besoin d'une
tonne d'équivalent pétrole on va les
ramener en France on va les asperges et
sur le sol à peu près à 30 kilos d'azote
par personne et ce qui va arriver en
nourriture par personne dans les foyers
basse à peu près 7 kg donc il a une
énorme perte en ligne et là tu il y a
des gens qui se sont amusés un peu à
faire une comptabilité azotée à
l'intérieur de la maison pour savoir
entre ce qui rentrait ce qui sort
qu'est-ce qui se passe alors là souvent
l'impression comme dans notre petit
compost sur le sur le balcon ou dans le
jardin et on a fermé le cycle des
matières organiques et ben en fait on a
travaillé seulement sur entre 20 et 1
car 20 pourcents un quart et bah de
l'azote qui était rentré dans la maison
les trois quarts part malheureusement
quand on tire la chasse dans notre pipi
et alors ça va dans le réseau d'égouts
ça va avec des grands tuyaux des station
de relevage et tout ça ça arrive à une
station d'épuration qui elle va faire
exactement le processus inverse mais on
dépensait autant d'énergie qu'au départ
et bah en fait elle va transformer cette
azote qui était solide qui était
potentiellement utilisable comme engrais
depuis le liquide donc y est l'urine et
elle va le transformer en azote de l'air
et là c'est vraiment dommage parce qu'on
a perdu en entrée en dépensant
énormément d'énergie en transformant les
autres de gaz à solide et là dans la
station d'épuration va dépenser
énormément d'énergie en changeant de
souris et malheureusement plus là
d'épuration elle le fait pas très bien
les rendements c'est 60 % donc il y a
une énorme quantité d'engrais qui va
arriver dans les rivières et qui crée un
phénomène qui s'appelle l'autre fixation
c'est l'asphyxie des cours d'eau par un
développement d'algues un peu trop
important alors ça c'était le cycle de
l'azote mais il y en a un qui est encore
plus problématique c'est le cycle du
phosphore en fait le phosphore c'est une
ressource non-renouvelable et celle-là
elle est très inégalement répartis dans
le monde ce que 80 % des réserves
mondiales sont situés au Maroc et en
fait comme c'est une ressource
non-renouvelable et ben elle va vers son
épuisement et on annonce son pic dans
deux ou trois décennies c'est-à-dire
qu'on va arriver assez rapidement en
fait dans moins de 20 ans à une
situation où l'offre ne va pas pouvoir
subvenir à la demande et là-bas on voit
bien les conflits que ça peut produire
ce qui est sûr c'est que dans 20 ans ça
va être une vraie problématique de
nourrir 7 milliards d'habitants ou plus
si on est plus donc voilà en fait sur
les engrais la France est dépendante à
100 % des importations nos sols ont
perdu en fertilité donc on arrive pas à
se débrouiller et il faut vraiment
remettre de la circularité parce que
notre système la d'alimentation
d'expression il est complètement
linéaire et est vraiment problématique
et en plus de ça si on rajoute un peu la
thématique de l'eau et ben on est en
zone très très rouge sur la Méditerranée
avec des prospective qu'ils annoncent
que le début des cours d'eau vont être
est réduit de 50 % et d'ici 30 ans donc
en gros on va mourir de soif il y aura
plus d'engrais donc on aura plus à
manger donc vous allez me dire mais
peut-être si on a bien mangé du coup et
ben on va faire moins caca comment va
faire caca envoie-moi tirer la chasse ça
tombe bien parce que il y aura moins
d'eau et peut-être qu'on va s'en sortir
comme ça nous on a eu très peur quand on
a appris tout ça et on se dit est-ce
qu'on peut pas parler à tous ces
problèmes en amenant des toilettes
sèches et donc et Cosec est là pour vous
sauver bon je vous parlez d'humidité au
début voilà on est arrivé un peu avec
plein d'espoir et on se dit mais on va
sortir ce pitch là tu n'osais lui et en
fait très rapidement ils vont installer
des cabines de toilette publique dans
toute la ville
imposer à tous les promoteurs
immobiliers que chaque nouvelle
construction et des raisons en séparatif
pour qu'on puisse recevoir les urines et
tout ça on va mettre une ceinture
maraîchère autour de la ville et on fait
les maraîchers ils vont amener des
aliments à l'intérieur de la vie et avec
le moyen de transport ils vont récupérer
les urines qui vont ramener et du coup
la ville elle sera complètement
résiliente elle sera indépendante et on
aura plus de problème et tu seras
circulaire et quand on leur a sorti tout
ça et ben en fait on a vérifié un
principe qui avait dit qu'ils étaient il
est beaucoup plus difficile de craquer
un préjugé que craquer un atome est la
donc on s'est pointé voir ses élus en
question qui nous ont dit oui mais en
fait nous on est deuxième au classement
de Shanghai donc avec vos toilettes
sèches je pense que vous devriez aller
sur le Larzac là-bas vous aurez
peut-être plus de clients quoi donc on
se dit assez vite il va falloir casser
cette imaginaire la sur la toilette
sèche parce que le fait de faire peur et
leur dire qu'on va tous mourir ça va pas
suffire donc on a fait des toilettes on
a bossé pour faire les toilettes
connecter Kippour une application pour
calculer le taux d'urée une collègue est
la quantité d'eau en avait un écran LED
qui nous est la quantité de économiser
on avait des trop serré on pouvait grave
est le nom du client sur la porte on a
fait tout ça et en fait on est un petit
peu passer par la fenêtre parce que les
premiers qui nous ont pris ils ont dit
bon vous êtes mignons avec vos histoires
d'écologie mais en fait moi mon problème
numéro 1 c'est que j'ai pas de réseau
donc est-ce que vos toilettes elles sont
pas connectés et non en fait il y a pas
de réseau puis elle marche un panneau
solaire et donc c'est sur cette fenêtre
là qu'on est rentré en premier en fait
on a compris et ça c'est peut-être un
truc ce que je vais je donne à tout ce
qui se passe dans l'écologie et qui
pense que l'argument fondamental ça
arrête de faire peur à tout le monde
c'est bon bah ça marche pas très bien
là-dessus on a tiré un peu la pelote et
je reviens un peu dans ce qui se passe
dans la maison parce que c'est assez
intéressant le tout-à-l'égout j'aimerais
le comparer un peu à notre vision
aujourd'hui des déchets solides tout le
monde comprends bien que si on trees à
la source le plastique l'aluminium le
fermentescible et les différents déchets
ou le vert et ben en fait ça fait des
filières qui sont beaucoup plus facile
sur leur site c'est la valorisation et
bah c'est pareil sur les cycles liquide
dans la maison qu'est-ce que c'est
dommage de gâcher tout les eaux grises
qu'on consomme un montpelliérain
consomme 145 litres par jour d'eau
potable et bah cette eau potable donc ça
représente 50 mètre cube à l'année et
bah Oury avec quoi seulement 20 litres
de matière fécale une fois que se
dessécher un humain ne produit que 20
litres et c'est dans ces matières
fécales comment être concentré tous les
pathogène est tous les choses en plus
c'est même pas très intéressant au
niveau agronomique le corps il a été
super intelligent il a séparé les urines
et les matières fécales dans les urines
il y a 80 % des engrais qui peuvent être
réutilisées et en plus c'est stérile
alors j'en entends qui vont dire oui mon
mari puisse au fond du jardin ça crame
tout l'herbe en fait c'est le même
principe quand médecine entre le remède
et le poison c'est qu'une question de
dosage voilà il faut bien doser et à
côté de ça effectivement il y a une
problématique qui est sur les résidus
pharmaceutique mais en fait aujourd'hui
il y a aucune station d'épuration qui
traite les résidus pharmaceutique donc
ça arrive dans les rivières les
poissons-chats bon je reviens mon cycle
de la maison qu'est-ce que ce serait
bien de garder cette eau grise quand on
prend une douche de 70 litres qu'est-ce
que c'est dommage elle est là pour rire
avec des matières fécales alors que
c'est tout il y a quoi il y a un peu de
salon et quelques poils et on pourrait
tout à fait l'utiliser pour faire du
végétal en ville et là je vous ramène un
peu à toute la campagne municipale dans
toutes les villes au moment des canicule
tout le monde dit mais il faut
végétalisé c'est ça qui va rafraîchir la
ville le problème c'est que Montpellier
et comme dans toute la Méditerranée on
est en zone rouge sur l'eau je vous le
disais la ville est dépendante pendant 4
mois des importations d'eau qui viennent
du Bas-Rhône et en fait s'il y avait pas
l'eau du baron et ben on aurait ni d'eau
dans l'Aisne ni donne en eau robinet et
qu'est-ce que c'est dommage de gâcher
toute cette quantité d'eau d'eau grise
qui pourrait très utilisé pour pas faire
de la nature et la nature et ben en fait
elle a un phénomène qui est utilisé par
le corps humain aussi qui est
l'évaporation de l'eau en fait on crée
du frais quand on quand on su et donc
c'est la transformation de l'état
liquide à l'état gazeux qui va créer du
frais et nous on aimerait bien proposé à
tous les villes en fait de les refroidir
lors des épisodes caniculaire avec des
murs végétaux on a calculé qu'on arrive
à refroidir un bâtiment entre 10 et 15
degrés avec des murs végétaux qui sont
irriguer juste avec l'eau de nos douches
et les urines et ça en fait quand on va
voir un promoteur et ben c'est un
argument qui nous fait passer par la
fenêtre qui est beaucoup plus sympa que
tant que l'argument écologique juste de
lui dire vous rendez compte les
économique climatisation vous allez
faire en plus de tous les miens fait
d'avoir un bâtiment perdre donc on se
crée aujourd'hui on est cet employé on
est en Scop on est entreprise
d'insertion et on essaie de se déployer
on a mis nos premières 3 cabines au
centre ville de Paris c'est des gens en
insertion qui viennent en vélo les
nettoyer parce que du coup on a plus de
nettoyage automatique et demain on va
faire le premier bâtiment à
Dol-de-Bretagne de 34 logements
entièrement en séparatif et on espère
que petit à petit et ben la pelote va se
tirer et qu'on va développer toutes ces
technologies là qu'on va pouvoir
récupérer toute cette quantité d'eau en
plus de cette quantité d'urine et
pouvoir bas tous vous sauver d'une mort
certaine voilà merci de votre attention